[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
greetings i am brian wood from the pr
department at wolfram uh today i'm going
to be chatting with development manager
bob sam heinrich uh how you been bob
i'm doing great how are you rand uh
doing good doing good
uh bob's here to talk about something i
think we can all relate to which is
uh just having fun um more specifically
uh we're gonna look at some quick fun
hacky side projects
that bob's working on with uh wolfram
technology
uh so give me the lowdown what kinds of
projects are you talking about here
well it can be just about anything i
i've been
working at will from developing in
wolfram language
so long that it tends to invade my brain
and change the way i think about things
so
uh you know what i encounter
things in my life that i think are
interesting or challenging or that could
be done and i
immediately start thinking about them uh
computationally or even the lines of
code enter enter my thoughts
um so yeah and and it's uh
remarkable with such a automated
high-level language
how you can take those uh spontaneous
ideas
that you know are just sort of come into
your life
about different things and turn them
into real products
and uh and a lot of times it's not
anything
serious it's not something that i'm
being paid to do for my job but it's
uh it's just uh something that i
i enjoy and have fun and you end up
making something real
yeah and i think that's a kind of a good
mentality for anybody who's
into something as that can be as
intensive as development
if you if you do a lot of coding then
you know it's easy to
sort of feel like you've got to have
your head down doing something
productive and
uh but a lot of times it's you know you
end up
coming out with something even better or
sort of get the creative juices flowing
if you sort of just
do whatever feels fun um so yeah so what
uh why don't we go ahead and just dive
in and uh
take a look at uh some of the stuff that
you have built just
just for fun like you said sure sure
i'll go ahead and
show my my notebook here
so i have a few projects lined up
um you know one of them is uh
pie slices daily so i
a lot of people who follow wolfram on
twitter or
know the company are probably familiar
with my pi day
it's uh it's it's this website where you
can put in your birthday and it tells
you where your birthday is
um and so yeah that's been around for a
few years
and i've had some uh tangential
work to do with it but so every year it
comes around and we get lots of web hits
and people start
thinking about it again and and yeah it
it
what what's remarkable is just how easy
it is to
find arbitrary digits even deep into pi
it's super fast
uh i'm not i'm not one of these uh
uh math guys who can tell you all the
algorithms behind
finding people in deeper digits by but
it's it's it's all just right here
um so uh i and i thought
that a couple other pieces
that are in the the wolfram technology
stack could help me make something fun
so uh this year sometime around
or last year i guess sometime around pi
day i just happened to be
working with the twitter service
connection
so we have this service connect function
in the wolfram language
that takes you here and you can say
you can authorize you can authorize
twitter you come back here
and you know you can connect it so you
can do things like
get all the all the tweets from well
from research
or the last 20 whatever but you can also
send tweets so i i did this earlier and
i don't want to lie
so uh there's there's this
and and if i go if i go back to twitter
then here's here's the the tweet i just
sent from mathematica so
uh you can you can you can yeah this is
not
my my real twitter um uh
so you can you can send stuff uh to
twitter easily so that's another piece
of the puzzle
and then the third piece of the puzzle
is a scheduled test
so it's very easy to set up some tasks
to run in uh wolfram cloud
on a schedule so here's here's the line
of code that
deploys the schedule test so what this
is doing is it's
calculating the temperature in st louis
subtracting the temperature
in champagne urbana and
labeling it with the time stamp and
putting it in a in a cloud object it's
just appending it to cloud job
and i run this every six hours and i've
deployed it
into a cloud object so every six hours
that adds things so
i i started this when i the first when i
started writing this notebook just as a
good example
and you can see i've got uh several days
worth of data here
and and i can you know work with that
data directly so there's
scheduled tasks are a very useful tool
that i use
uh every day so
when you put those pieces together you
find
that you can create one of the greatest
websites that i've ever seen which is
pie slices daily
so what i just made is a uh
a cloud deployed scheduled test that
every day
calculates the next 280 digits of pi
and sends it to twitter and you can it's
been running for
a little over a year uh and pretty much
without
any issue and every day i get this
absurd little thing that makes me giggle
uh and maybe maybe it can make anyone
else giggle too so
uh and all the code to generate it is
is here in github in in in my github
account so
i can see the account here it's yeah and
it's
all it's very very little code here
um just for calculating the digits
sending it to twitter
uh most of it is basically error
handling you know it whenever you're
doing
things uh with servers occasionally some
things can give an error so basically
i did a lot of work so that if it fails
the next day
it'll start over where it was supposed
to go instead of skipping digits because
that would be embarrassing
[Laughter]
so so yeah that that that was just sort
of a a lark that i thought would be fun
to just sort of every day tweet out the
next 280 characters
um and and by all means i hope that
somebody
goes through and checks my digits and
tells me
tells me if i'm missing something right
yeah because because who would uh
who would even know right but um yeah
yeah yeah
that's a that's a lot of fun yeah and
just uh just to
take a step back for the uninitiated uh
we we you talked a little bit about pi
day
i know that uh that's march 14th um
because we we
the way that we do our dates 314
in the us just uh just for those who
weren't sure about that but um
all right yeah so daily daily slices of
of pie
uh yeah which the punch is also very
much appreciated actually
i was gonna name the twitter account
daily slices of pie but it was taken
so interesting now it's pie slices daily
but well
i was right there in the same same
thought process as you that was
the name i came up with awesome
yeah so another fun thing i made is
uh a random haiku generator so i work
with the function repository is
a good chunk of my day-to-day job and
a while ago we had uh this
this function word syllables um that we
published in the function repository so
this it represents actually a
significant amount of work from
mark greenberg who must know something
about linguistics
i can't say i do but it's not a trivial
thing to say
where syllables in a word are it might
seem
easy but it's not but he put a lot of
work in it works
pretty well um i haven't found a lot of
cases where
uh it it fails um so i saw this
nice serious function and decided that i
could do something stupid with it uh
so i made another function in the
function repository
called random english haiku which is
about
five lines of code using his syllables
function
that generates haikus
uh from from word list by just finding
finding words random words that fit um
so that is fun
but then to take it make it one more
step fun
i decided to make a little web app
that would generate haikus for me so
this is i'm not a web coder
this represents the the height of my
abilities
uh a little bit of css and
what i get is this guy
so so now we have this you know it looks
very poetic
in cursive font and
every time every time you refresh it
you'll get another
thing this this compiler stock bind that
that looks like something that comes out
of a
a build failure it does seem it's one of
our
important message yes ayatollah shaker
[Laughter]
yeah you know don't shake your
ayatollahs folks
i i would almost i can almost see using
this as
uh sort of just creative inspiration for
writing you know just
here's some random words yeah and oh
look here's a phrase that
actually makes sense and you know maybe
you can just uh
pull a story out of that that's uh yeah
that's a lot of fun yeah i
i do not see any real use cases but if
you do
more power to you yeah well either way
it is uh
you know it's kind of cool that you were
able to take someone else's
well just to give a little bit of
context for uh wolfram function
repository
that's anybody can submit their own
functions to that and basically make
them accessible
from a wolfram notebook so i just think
it's cool that you're able to go
and see oh someone else has made this
function
i'm gonna sort of reply with my own
function and you know there's that
interesting
kind of uh community feel where where
it's like oh yeah okay we're all
kind of creating our own thing and uh we
can we can kind of share it and
your idea was obviously a little bit
different from mark's original idea so
it's
you know it's kind of cool to see how
those things evolve yeah
yeah the collaboration with between
somebody who does serious work and
someone who doesn't
um so yeah the next fun project i had is
definitely
near and dear to my heart because i'm a
baseball fan um and if there are any
baseball fans out there they're probably
familiar with baseballreference.com this
website
uh is you know a statistical paradise
for baseball fans it's been around
surprisingly long time 20 years or
something
um and it has it has data on on players
here oh ray langford
great outfielder number 16 for the
cardinals when i was growing up
um that goes back uh yeah
all the way to the the late 1800s
on every player who's ever set foot on a
major league diamond
so that data is there and uh they don't
have
a built api but uh it's not hard to make
a scraper
in the wolfram language so i did that
and actually before i evaluate all this
i'm going to
show where it is in github so in github
we have
i have this this baseball reference
graph project
and here is all the code
so a lot of times it's just import of an
xml object
and then doing some uh cases
on the xml for for specific patterns so
it's just
importing stuff as xml and doing doing
pattern
matching and manipulation yeah um and so
so the scraping code is not long
um so i made that so i can do things
like get a list of all the teams
in major league baseball get a list of
every year that a
random team has has been active so the
royals have been around since 1969
and then what i can do is i have this
team year player grass that takes
all of these uh pat all these
relative urls for baseball reference and
uh scrapes the players from each of
those pages
and creates a graph um so here i'm you
doing
all the teams and just from the years
1980 to 1981
and it's going to come back with
a graph last time it took about 20
seconds
so we'll see 15 my internet's getting
faster
and we can we can look at the graph
here sometimes that takes even longer
so in this case on this graph uh each
little vertex the little tiny light blue
lighter blue dots
is a player and every
line connecting them to another player
means that they were teammates on a
given year
which allows us to create sort of a
a six degrees of kevin bacon scenario
so if we grab two random vertices from
from the graph
we could find shortest path is super
fast those only have one people but
one player between them let's see okay
here we got two
we have these player codes i set it up
so that annotation values on the graph
have the real name so you can see
connecting jesus vega
to john tamargo i've never heard of him
uh
is is via two players uh
and then what i can do to make uh
another
fun little web app is deploy this graph
to cloud so i'm just exporting it
to mx in a cloud object and
then i can create another cloud object
that
imports this this player graph
and calls this random story function
which was defined
in that same github document that i
showed a minute ago
and what you get is is this
little guy which has no styling
could be could be much prettier um but
uh it tells random stories about
baseball players in 1981
and 1980 so that's connecting pat
sheridan and mark souza
and each one of these i've set up so
that's a link back to the baseball
reference page
oh cool cool and and
of course when i had more than uh 20
seconds
to to get data i
also set this up to grab all 120 plus
years
that uh that baseball reference has data
on
and so now we can create random stories
over longer periods of time those two
both happen to be in 1964.
let's see here we go jim russell and
blake stein
oh wow connecting a player from the 49
braves with the
98 a's ricky anderson we got n warren
spawn and filmmaker oh we got three hall
of famers
that's a good one let's get one let's
save that one let's save that one for
the catalog
three three hall of famers um
so yeah and i just i just think it's
really fun
i'm a baseball fan and like the stories
of
baseball are just
you know warm my heart um so so it
i i can sit here and play with this for
uh
for minutes on end um
yeah and the old and if if if
if only for the nicknames of the
old-timey players
yeah one of the greatest problems with
modern baseball is the nicknames have
really gone down yeah yeah that is kind
of a shame i i
i i've never really been too into
baseball but looking
at well i mean for instance the just the
number
of points on that graph that you showed
i i would never have thought about how
uh
how connected the the different players
are on their teams and
this story thing is really interesting
because i
you know you sort of don't don't really
think about
that uh span of time where you know
this person might have been playing for
20 years and crossed over with that
other person
and it's then crossed over with someone
else right yeah
it does make for uh i mean you have guys
like carly ostremski
who played for a long time with the red
sox and he
so he'll show up on a lot of grass what
i found is
undoubtedly the uh
the most connected player is minnie
minoso who was a twins player one of the
first cubans in baseball
and he uh he
what's notable about him is after he had
retired
even in his like early 40s he was
coaching
or managing uh and there was some
player issue where they asked him to
suit up for
a few games in his mid-50s and so he has
this whole new generation of players
that he's connected to
so and one of them is harold baines and
it's a ma who also who was
young then and played another a long
career
and so a large percentage of
the the results have many minoso goes to
harold baines
to connect players from like you know
1950 to like
1998 or some something in that range wow
yeah
just just those two guys um so it's fun
because
every person has a has a story
about their life behind it then and it's
fun to
sort of put that all together so this
one this one
you know it probably took a couple hours
to develop the code and then a couple
more hours to do all the scraping
and and then i have this this fun thing
that i can play with
at some point i need to go back and do a
couple of more hours to make it look
like not garbage
but yeah that's more important to some
people than it is to me
right right uh another thing that
started off as a hacky side project is
some
coven 19 tools that i that i worked on
that's
i don't really want to get into because
as you'll see here
uh it's not a little side heck anymore
so this is in the wolfram research
github uh repo and yeah it's sort of
grown into this
this uh larger full package of code
um and what what i'm trying to
demonstrate here is that
these little side hack projects that i
just i
yeah i in once again the function
repository there are some functions for
bringing in data from new york times or
covatracking.com
um or from the wolfram data repository
we keep updated data there
right uh and we have so we had these
tools for bringing the data but i wanted
to
make something that was easy for me to
customize it to my region because i
really
thought that like metro areas was the
scale that we wanted to look at
um so so so i put that together and then
it's sort of
every every once in a while i come back
and add new features to it and it's
grown into
uh this packet where i have this deploy
metro data
that makes uh this this
dashboard that's just a cloud notebook
that that i
update every couple days to see how the
st
louis region is doing and i've
generalized it so that most of this
stuff
works for any location you put in it
grabs you know eight counties around you
from here in the new york times data and
gets it some of the other stuff like
like this metro area hospital data there
isn't a
good source for arbitrary regions like
there's for the
cases and deaths from new york times but
you know this is something that i've
definitely used to try to
keep my finger on the pulse of of of
you know the the epidemic in my area
sure yeah yeah i mean who wouldn't want
to right that's uh
sort of been on everyone's mind right um
yeah and i do think it's it's
a good example of how the at least for
me
um getting something that you can sort
of
create incremental results you're like
okay well this isn't the final thing
but i do have something that's
interesting so you know
it's a lot more satisfying to kind of
build it up that way when
you might only be you know 10 of the way
through
what you think of as the final project
but you still have some result to show
so
um like you said it might start off as a
little bit of a hacky kind of side
project
um but just the fact that you can get
real results from that
kind of inspires you to want to build
just a little bit more onto it
absolutely absolutely when you can when
you can break it down to pieces and get
something real
within half an hour it totally motivates
moving forward and it's not this
giant monolithic challenge that is so
for boarding that you don't want to
even wade into it right right yeah
because again it can be really uh
well yeah foreboding like you said it's
it's very intimidating to uh think of a
large-scale programming project
uh without having those those little
incremental steps so
awesome well uh this is definitely been
uh an interesting slice of programming
if uh
if you don't mind the pie slices pun
yeah um yeah
and uh everyone should definitely check
out the uh what was what was the twitter
called
pie slices daily pie slices daily so
check out pie slices daily
um obviously anybody looking to do these
kinds of fun little
projects uh with their own wolfram cloud
account can do so
uh you can just go to wolfram cloud it's
free to get started
and uh again the the wolfram function
repository is a good resource
like you said you found a few things on
there you added a few things on there
yep um and uh everyone anyone who's
watching this
obviously don't be afraid to experiment
and um don't forget to have some fun
absolutely absolutely coding can be fun
yeah
yeah and and you can get real stuff real
quick with art with
will from tech tech so indeed so just
play around
yeah play yeah play around that's a good
that's a good note to end on thanks a
lot for talking to me bob yeah it was
fun
thanks brad thanks for joining us
you can check out other wolfram tech
talks live coding streams and more on
the wolfram research youtube channel
or see what else is new at wolfram.com
you